la fermeté affichée par les officiels
russes laisse penser que les frappes sur
l'Ukraine vont se poursuivre voir
qu'elles vont s'intensifier en
représailles à la visite de vous le dire
zalinski aux États-Unis des frappes qui
se sont abattues en nombre en début de
semaine sur qui a fait sa région
toujours en grande partie plongée dans
le noir c'est le reportage de nos
envoyés spéciaux à Kiev les naphologies
son grand espoir quelques résidents
viennent tenter leur chance à la
fontaine à haut du quartier en vain
on avait NiO ni chauffage ni lumière de
9 heures à 21h c'est terrible
aujourd'hui c'est depuis 8 heures du
matin
depuis le bombardement de la veille le
courant est de nouveau coupé et il n'y a
pas d'issue
je ne sais plus quoi faire je n'ai pas
d'argent pour partir à l'étranger
Irina tient à nous emmener chez elle
pour nous montrer dans quelles
conditions elle vit retraitée elle n'a
pas les moyens d'acheter un générateur
vous voyez il n'y a pas de lumière
fonctionne à l'électricité alors tout se
débranche le frigo était branché tout
est en train de pourrir les radiateurs
sont froids aussi touché vous allez voir
par des températures négatives les
ouvriers de 10 tech la compagnie qui
gère le réseau de distribution ukrainien
travail 24 heures sur 24 pour pallier
l'urgence après 9 vagues de frappe
contre les infrastructures énergétiques
le réseau du pays est endommagé à plus
de 50%
au siège de la société le directeur nous
explique qu'une frappe de plus et Kiev
sera totalement circuit
la situation est vraiment critique comme
vous pouvez le voir à Kiev et sa région
après la dernière attaque de drone ça
fait déjà deux jours que nous ne
parvenons pas à stabiliser la situation
à la nuit tombée en plus de la menace de
nouveaux bombardements quelques 3
millions d'habitants de Kiev doivent
composer avec une capitale plongée dans
l'obscurité ou le Seigneur je voulais
les rues sont obscures et peu fréquentés
nos téléphones n'ont plus de batterie il
fait nuit tôt et quand on rentre de
l'école à la maison on a peur
ce sont des bandes réfléchissantes pour
que les voitures me voient quand je
traverse la rue les
Ukrainiens s'adaptent mais leurs
conditions de vie se durcissent de jour
en jour
d'occidentale distille et leur seul
espoir face à un hiver de bombardements